it's gaming week on this channel and you
clicked on this video because you're a
gamer that's right
you may not know it but if you ever
played Sudoku on your phone you're a
gamer goddammit G fuel is pumping
through your veins so let's just jump
into it we're doing you life you lose
gaming edition cuz gaming never stops oh
great I'm laughing only because it's
minecraft now I get it
I get the minecraft name I can be part
of the joke look at Kate because he's
chubby chump now I just have to watch
Jojo then I can finally be part of all
the meanness groups yay they need to do
this with all relatable Instagram
Carboni then they will actually be funny
hey delete this delete this right now
[Music]
buddy beautiful only real gamers
understand only true gamers knows what
it's night
shut up I'm not crying okay first-grader
rain rain go away come again another
date the rain
oh god I'm dying oh wait it's gamer week
intimate life baby
glug-glug good don't say you know art
unless you know the classics goddamn is
that the art in Minecraft god damn
that's some edgy it's out of salad
that's awesome I'm a teacher and you're
my student I've been meaning to play
this okay gamers be right back I have to
play video game my god oh my chair pants
Oh me Japan
Devi amen let's go what I didn't see you
come in Devi where did you come from I
don't worry about it
that's sick I've actually been there I
know no one cares but they actually I
didn't realize they actually model after
Devi oh come on they were making songs
together that's so sad come on why is
she in God David these are so shorts how
am I gonna get your mummy no you great
20:18 memes everyone that's good though
why did I not see this this is what
happens when you take a break from
gaming you lose all touch unbelievable
your mom gay know even how to
disseminate and they make totes
don't say it Noblet disappointed oh heck
yeah I wish it was more of these they're
so good
[Music]
there's the one with the guys I can't
find it it's a guy carrying a giant log
or something please find it for me I
want to see it everyone's reaction to
the first boss in Dark Soul
do the stanky leg if you're enjoying
this episode right now how do i do
stinking life Thank You leg Thank You
leg okay I know how to do stanky leg if
you're a gamer you can do the stanky leg
too
but only if you're a gamer
god forbid you if you do it without all
the gamers have license
what kind of modest this is resident
evil it is damn it I want a full version
please actual footage from Russian
sewers
this is great can we have the groom walk
out walk out this is so sad it's gonna
be me when I walk out oh wait hold on
hold on
oh no he's sad what's wrong buddy oh
yeah he's happy I think that's gonna be
fine you wanna watch this guy yeah let's
what's a little flower oh I've seen this
but it's beautiful well god damn this
game looks old Jesus Christ
oh my god I was good I like that
hi okay answer what how did we get out
this far no more guess oh it's so good
[Music]
one of my favorite hey look his Russians
again what are they up to this time what
is this
[Laughter]
what's with Russians and buttholes
explain if you're Russian gamer explain
what is this I never actually played our
Finnish Dark Souls 3 gamers okay alright
very epic are those players are
[Music]
ok gamer moment oh my god is that a Dark
Souls oh I need to play Dark Souls 3
right now
what's with Russians and poopy holds I
just assume they're Russian
sorry gamers
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so beautiful
oh the client oh my god yeah that's
about the only reaction allowed for if
that happens surprise he didn't have a
gamer moment
Wow amazing someone probably spent a lot
of time programming that right speaking
like that wouldn't he be realistic God
on well done gamer Jesus Christ dude oh
[Laughter]
look at this dude
not bothered at all very epic what
oh my god oh my god is a crossover event
oh my god they tie its big head they're
so beautiful
yeah that was beautiful well duh oh that
those are the best
heavy rain feeling this is so good I
love this so much I washes a million
times you're a slob Korda yeah
lieutenant Carter Blake I'd like to ask
you some quick
don't just stand there he's gonna get
away
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right all right
the best one is Shawn though come on
[Music]
why is it funny it's not even funny
I've seen this too many times for so
bigfooting they don't make games like
the use oh wait they do oh wait there's
still dude definitely oh wait there's
one there's one I forgot what was it
what's that he's gonna eat us do you
remember that one come on it's gaming
week help a brother out where he goes
help us help us he's gonna eat us there
it is
yeah Angela this is the best story on my
English [ __ ] Mike oh yeah I'm making a
fire do you have some beef for me you
know someplace some some bacon I'm from
human state I'm from Austria we just
need something to eat
thank you dude thank you you're very
friendly man very friendly I take it
finest in my house okay I have done it I
think we need some more meat right no
maybe that my friend with the yellow him
no no that's a Shannara dude what's up
what the hell the rats wrong with you
help me there is a guy in the fire
station help guard in the fire station I
don't kill you using me you will eat me
[ __ ] [ __ ] settle down settle down
I used to read all the Hawks ain't much
I come in january 1st asia so again what
are you for [ __ ] [ __ ] thanks relax
no one relax not you will know I'm
relaxed not go in and kill this
[ __ ] anything hey where you
going hey do you guys want to play again
heads or tails I have a better tactical
game Simon said you're the [ __ ]
[ __ ] no I don't like the game you
first you first van amudha had corrected
sorry it's tails scheming he's not my
friend I just seen him about 20 minutes
before
no no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] me
yesterday I have to meet is the meat of
your mother one yeah yeah yeah you
understand me I know you understand me
[Music]
you're free no I'm gonna go ten out of
ten absolutely wonderful gaming week is
going on but it's thanks to you guys and
your support never say thank you very
much every gamer stinky leg and I see
you guys next time
Oh merch question mark okay epoch link
description what you never played super
simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]